Layla Jane is an 18 year old
d-transitioner she's a girl
who was pushed into transition all these
horrible mutilations and chemical
injections when she was a little kid now
she's 18.
and she says she greatly regrets it and
she's suing her doctors here's her story
I really want to say that I think you
can hear it right away
the people who tell you there are no
long-term consequences it's all totally
reversible if a child starts to
transition
and then stops transitioning it's no big
deal this girl's voice is quite deep and
it's going to be deep for the rest of
her life and there's nothing to change
about that this girl has aspects now in
her body which are quite masculine
because she was pushed into this as a
kid and there's no reversal for that and
someone has to be held accountable as
she says
it should have been allowed to change my
sex before I could legally consent to
have sex overall I don't think I'm
better off for the experience and I
think transition just completely added
fuel to the fire that was my
pre-existing conditions
her pre-existing conditions she's
talking about psychological conditions
conditions that I am not even allowed to
mention on certain big Tech platforms I
am not even allowed to suggest that
transgender identity
has significant let's say overlap with
other
[Music]
conditions let's say am I allowed to say
that can I say that one sensors
Layla's saying that she's saying this
happened to me and I wasn't treated for
other
conditions I had I was treated as though
I were really a boy and now I deeply
regret it they did this to me before I
was even legally allowed to consent to
sex her lawyer is our friend Harmony
Dylan here's what harmit says
when the mental health
jury and it and it was closed to her
family or to her that that for example a
teenage transitioners desist from
transition at a 80 to 90 percent rate
that the majority of people who go
through this uh regret it later on that
it wasn't a solution for her mental
health problems that many girls in fact
most girls probably struggle with
puberty and so it is our position
legally as a matter of law that informed
consent was missing here because it is
it impossible for a child to give
informed consent and it is impossible
for parents who are not fully informed
and with a child that was not properly
treated to also give that consent and
Laura an important Point here is that
you know we you've had me on with our
client Chloe Cole as well and Kaiser
doctors use the line on her and her
parents would you rather have a live son
or a dead daughter the exact same line
was used in this case so it appears to
be a script that certain Kaiser doctors
and psychiatrists are using on on these
victims
this kind of
Butchery
is totally irresponsible at the levels
of the parents yes at the levels of the
school yes
but at the level of the doctors okay the
doctors need someone needs to be held
responsible and what you're going to
hear from the squishes as well the
doctors were just doing their jobs well
we shouldn't look people should be free
to choose whatever they want well
Layla's point is I can't be free to
choose whatever I want when I'm 13. I'm
30 I'm below the age of consent
okay and for for these these people
whose job it is first to do no harm to
be making these life-altering decisions
for me before I can consent
is deeply deeply wrong
you know how it's wrong you know how we
know it's wrong because the federal
government which now pretends that
transitioning at a very young age is
wonderful and great and we support
transiting the kids even the Biden
official who is in charge of that
Richard Levine who now calls himself
Rachel
admitted in a clip that's now cropped up
that he is grateful that he did not
transition until he was an adult I have
no requests because if I transitioned
when I was young and I wouldn't have my
children
I can't imagine a life without my
children and so every experience led me
to here and
um and so how could I regret that
he makes a great Point had he
transitioned that is to say been
castrated when he was a little kid he
wouldn't have been able to have children
and for so many of these d transitioners
one of the most painful aspects of the
regret is that they've been sterilized
that they've been castrated that they
won't be able to have kids I look at my
little kids this is the this is the
greatest joy that I can imagine in this
world at least
and you don't think about that when
you're 13 when you're 14 when you're
going through puberty when you're going
through an awkward phase when you've got
some anxiety about your body when your
friends are all wrapped up in this
bizarre fad of gender ideology and
you're sucked into it you don't think
about those things but but
even just a few years later even at 18
you can begin to think of that and say
oh my goodness what have I done and the
children should not be held responsible
for what's been done the parents should
the schools should the government should
and the doctors should and if we don't
hold them responsible if we don't
insist upon consequences for bad
behavior
you're going to get more of that bad
behavior and that's unjust certainly to
the victims it's unjust even to the
perpetrators meanwhile what are the
Democrats doing
well we just got new information from a
house oversight committee
that another Biden has been taking money
from communist China according to house
oversight quote
over the course of several years members
of the Biden family and their their
companies received over 1.3 million
dollars in payments from accounts
related to their associate Rob Walker
most of this money came as a result of a
wire from a Chinese Energy company and
went not only to Hunter and James Biden
James as Joe Biden's brother
but also to Hallie Biden Hallie Biden
if I'm getting my Biden women straight
was
is Beau Biden's Widow
and then the paramour of Hunter Biden
after that as well as an unknown Biden
who is the unknown Biden one can only
speculate
the corruption
is barely hidden it's not even hidden
when Hunter Biden was on the take and he
was being paid 50 Grand a month or
thereabouts by a Ukrainian State Energy
company barisma
that was pretty Brazen corruption Hunter
Biden doesn't know anything about
Ukraine Hunter Biden doesn't know
anything about the energy industry
Hunter Biden wasn't providing any
services to burisma other than giving
access to the vice president of the
United States who is now the president
of the United States who was a who was
Biden's I'm sorry who was Obama's Point
person on Ukraine I sometimes say oh
Biden because it seems to be the same
cabal of people
it would that was Brazen transparent
corruption
now
we find out the bidens have been on the
take from communist China they haven't
even really been been masking it and
washing the money through different
people the wire came from a Chinese
Energy company so the wire came with
direct Fingerprints of the Chinese
Communist party on it
are any of the bidens looking at any
consequences for this no
no if if the bidens had used their own
money to pay some alleged hush payment
to a porn star then they'd have the book
thrown at them but if they're taking
corrupt money from communist China to
sell American influence overseas not
really disclose this money it's just
coming out now oh that's totally fine
barely hidden two tracks of Justice
and it's the squish conservatives who
are the ones saying well we can't
violate our Norms maybe we should just
let them arrest the leader of the
opposition just this week because we
don't like he's very mean and sends Mean
Tweets some back when he was allowed to
have a Twitter account he does and so
let's just let's just move on
can we just move on please
to preserve the Norms in our sacred
democracy yeah I don't think so
I don't think so I don't think we can do
that the rest of the show continues now
you don't want to miss it become a
member use code Knowles Canada wlas at
checkout for two months free on all
annual plans we will see you over at the
membrane segment room
[Music]